apesar de visualmente atrativos são
verdadeiras armadilhas açucaradas
proporcionando o que chamamos de
carboidratos vazios desprovidos de
nutrientes essenciais esses grãos
transgênicos de cereais vem carregado
com açúcares corantes aromatizantes e
conservantes para mascarar essa
realidade e dar a sensação de ser
saudável eles adicionam uma série de
vitaminas sintéticas que nosso corpo
pode não ser capaz de utilizar o que nos
resta é uma camuflagem enganosa que
oculta o verdadeiro culto conteúdo
desses alimentos excesso de Açúcar que
pode causar dependência e prejudicar a
saúde a situação piora quando esses
cereais são consumidos no café da manhã
eles podem desencadear um aumento
descontrolado dos níveis de açúcar no
sangue iniciando assim um ciclo contínuo
de consumo que pode levar a obesidade e
diabetes o que realmente precisamos para
iniciar bem o dia é uma fonte
consistente de fibras gorduras saudáveis
e proteínas